issue with chase claypool the steelers
receiver we got to mention this because
you never know what the league's going
to do under the personal conduct policy
the league has so much discretion it can
do whatever it wants frankly a video
emerged it was overnight
tuesday into wednesday yeah chase
claypool from march 13 a fight at a bar
in southern california that spilled out
into the street at one point it looks
like he goes up to a guy who's on the
ground and gives him a kick then there's
a guy who lunges at claypool and lands
face first on the ground it looks like
claypool maybe like shoves his head back
into the asphalt
hey
chris look these guys got to know when
to disengage
whether you're whether you're a pro
athlete or not i tell my son all the
time if you're out if you're somewhere
if you sense anything going down just
get the hell out of there because number
one you don't know who has a gun that's
true you're right just get the hell out
just have that instinct of something's
going down and i'm getting the hell out
of here and especially if you're a guy
whose subject to discipline from your
employer for anything you do anywhere
you are
yeah get the hell out of there when you
see something going down yeah that's
right he's got too bright of a future i
mean he could be a superstar well you
you've heard me talk about him for the
last two years he's got everything you
want
everything he's one of those guys when
he walks and he walks in the room you go
what you're a receiver holy crap did
they build you in a lab like i mean he
is a freak of nature on the field off
the field i he wasn't
he looked like he was trying to kind of
just keep the peace and things like that
and people kept coming until he kicked
the guy well the kick was okay you know
again a fight broke out but you're right
i'm not disagreeing with you it's not
the most egregious thing in the world
either and then when a guy comes out you
i mean yeah i don't know what that guy
would had already drank or smoked but
you weren't picking a guy who's on the
ground yeah look i love chase claypool
but kicking a guy on the ground isn't
cool
yeah i don't know i'm saying that when a
face breaks out like that some things
happen but you're right about disengage
you're right you're right and then
here's the here's the other reason yeah
everywhere you go
anything you do i know canon will be
used against you because somebody else
is recording it no doubt that's why we
even know about it because back in the
old days you'd hear 50 different
versions about what happened you
wouldn't even know that he kicked
anybody oh what back in the old days we
might not have had the raiders the
steelers the giants or any of those
teams they had all been in jail who
knows what the hell would have happened
uh but again i i don't think it looked
egregious enough for the nfl to take
action
yeah he gave a little kick it wasn't
like he crushed the guy's face or
anything i mean it didn't look like he
made like square contact the guy
attacked him and he basically just threw
him on the ground and that was it but
you're i'm not arguing with your point
it's just it's a different day and age
there's a lot of fake tough guys out
there and it's just not worth it for for
what he's got in front of him as a
football player
the nfl's personal conduct policy is a
tool of public relations that's all it
is 99.99
of all the employers out there wouldn't
care about something like this they're
not going to do anything to you for
something like this these are things
that happen on your own time away from
work there are some states where you
better be careful what you do
for to someone who engages in some sort
of misbehavior when they're not at work
the only reason it's permissible in the
nfl setting is the union's agreed to the
personal conduct policy has agreed to
and authorized the policing of players
in their private lives
but because the nfl has so much
discretion you know there are times when
they exercise that discretion to not
turn
a small issue into a big issue that's
happened i believe
and and also
claypool could be the victim of
circumstance where this is a good
opportunity to remind all these players
number one that there is a personal
conduct policy you know because post ray
rice so many guys changed their ways and
complied we may be getting into a new
generation of players who don't really
understand they haven't they haven't
experienced in the locker room yeah
secondhand what happens when a guy gets
suspended and also after a year after a
year of everyone being at home yeah guys
are out and about again
i'm telling you
claypool could get whacked by the nfl
for this
simply to send a message to all the
other players out there and i'm not
saying he's gonna face a six-game
suspension that's the baseline
suspension for any act of violence and
we see the act of violence on tape
but he could get something
just as a way to publicize to all
players don't mess around now that
you're back in a position where you can
go out to bars be smart don't be stupid
disengage and if you don't you're going
to face the consequences
mike i i don't disagree you might be
right i don't think this is one that
deserves that i don't think it's quite
egregious enough and you know to what
you're saying we could we could talk
about a segment about guys who got stuff
they didn't i get it but you know i
think deshawn watson's reminding
everybody just
you know
plenty well
i know it's not the same but it's still
yeah it's still you know get your butt
in gear don't do do the right thing all
that type of stuff uh but yeah it's not
a good look for trace claypool and just
playful i hope i hope i hope
that the bar fight dynamic is far more
prevalent than the deshaun watson
dynamic i hope he's the only guy we're
in the area because of social social
media like where
you know
everyone's a a a fake tough guy it's
just the way it is it's you know i say
this on social media and there's just
too much i get it i mean and i'm nobody
but you know when you go out and do
things
people say things
you know as you walk by to get
underneath your skin or do that type of
stuff
and yeah you got to be mature and walk
away but it's worse now than ever people
are always like that and uh yeah it's
hard to avoid for a young guy why would
why would you say you're nobody you're
somebody i mean not like
you're somebody you're the son of phil
sims
i am i am the damn son of phil simms
you're right i'm proud of that you got a
problem with that screw off
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports